[Musique]
les bienvenus à l'usaf je vais vous
raconter un peu l'histoire de la
politique sociale à la réunion à partir
de la départementalisation mon enfance à
saint joseph c'était une enfance dans
une famille de petits agriculteurs
donc il fallait tout faire il fallait
aider les parents les corvées tout ça et
puis le problème c'était le déplacement
pour aller à l'école
donc on à l'école à pied après quand on
va au collège vincendo saint joseph on
allait en cas courants d'air la plupart
des familles vivaient en autarcie
c'est-à-dire vivait avec les produits de
la maison notre vie c'est
essentiellement le dimanche parce que
toute la semaine
c'était soit l'école soit les corvées
l'école pour nos parents ce n'était pas
la priorité
la priorité c'était de les aider dans
les champs
j'ai ce premier panneau qui va de 1975
1985 nous avons des points de repère
pour sur l'évolution de la
départementalisation à la réunion donc
vous avez dans les lois qui
progressivement seront applicables à la
réunion vous avez par exemple la
création de la caf la caisse dès que je
revienne en 1972 vous avez la mise en
place des études surveillées vous avez
le développement des vacances soit enfin
milices ont en colonie de vacances et
serra c'est le début de la prise en
compte des situations familiales le
développement des assauts familiale
s'est fait à l'intérieur
à l'intérieur donc de la région
catholique mais maintenant notre notre
institution est une institution laïque
et dans la gestion
nous nous entendons très bien et nous
faisons en sorte que toutes les
décisions soient prises à l'unanimité
la réunion est en retard par rapport à
ces départements métropolitains
on voit bien que dans les familles il ya
des difficultés il y a
le rapport à la santé il ya la mortalité
infantile qui est importante et on peut
expliquer pourquoi il ya les maladies
infantiles et puis bon ben il faudra
lancer la vaccination par exemple donc
au début de la démocratisation
on va lancer tout ça et après la
population augmente le nombre d'enfants
commente mois il faut créer des écoles
donc on va multiplier les écoles c'est
tout ça c'est le rattrapage qui vous
mettre en place les familles sont même
dépassés pour tout ça grâce à des portes
closes isation grâce à la bonne et
modernité nous avons atteint un niveau
social économique acceptable mais qu'il
faudra tout mettre en oeuvre pour que ce
niveau soit encore améliorée surtout
pour toute une frange de la population
qui vit encore dans des situations
souvent très difficile
[Musique]